protests like this one in mexico's
capital have been held across the
country calling for a surge in violence
against women to stop
[Applause]
it follows the murder of an 18 year old
student in the northern city of
monterrey
debony escobar's body was found on
thursday decomposing in a water tank
nearly two weeks after she'd gone
missing
she was left on the side of the road
late at night after a taxi driver
allegedly tried to fondle her
moments later he took this picture
he says it's proof that she was alive
when she got out of the car
the taxi driver claims he wasn't
involved in the woman's death it's a
case that's still under investigation
and has outraged the country
to be honest it happens too often it's
not just this case several women have
been murdered in a month that's why
we're here fighting
posters of missing girls and women were
taped outside the attorney general's
office activists say police and
prosecutors have been slow and
ineffective in investigating these cases
authorities don't do what they're
supposed to do in a timely fashion when
someone goes missing they continue
arguing that we need to wait 72 hours to
start searching instead of going forward
we seem to be going backwards
killings of women have increased in
recent years in mexico in 2020 records
show there were
977 registered cases
a year later 38 more were reported
we are not fools we do not need to be
lawyers or have a degree to see that
there is no justice not even in death
[Applause]
despite years of protest the number of
disappearances remains high
around 600 women have been reported
missing so far this year
officials say nearly 830 are still
unaccounted for and 16 have been found
dead
now that debony has been laid to rest
calls are mounting for justice
along with thousands of unsolved cases
katya lopez
al jazeera